les générations se suivent mais ne se
ressemblent pas je sais que celle à
laquelle j'appartiens qui est à peu près
celle de 68 n'aimait pas beaucoup
l'armée
et bien si j'en juge par un sondage qui
a été réalisé par notre confrère
l'étudiant nos successeurs les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui qui ont 20 ans ne sont pas
du tout des goûters par l'armée il
aimerait bien y aller même didier
chauveau le petit de l'armée l'honneur
de la patrie le sens du devoir des
notions que l'on croyait perdus chez les
jeunes appelés et bien détrompez-vous en
85 nos bidasses ont envie de prendre du
service certains aspects du service
national qui les rebute et autrefois
désormais les intéressent de plus en
plus un cadre professionnel structuré la
rigueur voire la discipline et le goût
de l'ordre mais on retrouve aussi dans
leur répondent certains clichés de leurs
prédécesseurs
qu'est ce que vous pensez du service
national bon c'est un truc ferquois
c'est utile pour fausse traversée des
fois on a parlé plus tôt contre la vie
c'est pour la france
ça dépend si on le prend dans le
contexte de son utilité à grande échelle
sert la guerre c'est assez débile
oui oui j'ai envie de partir au service
national ferme au service national et
pourquoi pourquoi parce que je pense
qu'on doit le faire c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut voir dans la vie moi je pense
que c'est indispensable
le service national est absolument
indispensable mais audio mesopinions g
patinoire pour pourquoi parce que je
suis un petit peu démodé je vous ai fait
un petit vieux ou actuels d'accord et
puis on perd une année en poussins
octobre au service militaire
cette année
si pour certains le service national est
bien souvent synonyme d'ennui de corvée
pour d'autres il est vécu comme une
préparation à la vie professionnelle
possibilité de suivre une formation un
besoin de se sentir prise en charge dans
un cadre structuré et protecteur
moi je résumerais assez bien ce qui se
passe dans l'esprit de beaucoup de
jeunes ce sens qu'ils vont trouver
là-bas un père un père un peu
autoritaire
le colonel est le père de son régiment
sans doute et puis surtout des frères
c'est à dire une occasion de camaraderie
alors on peut se demander si
l'institution militaire ne joue pas son
rôle à un moment de la vie des individus
en leur fournissant une sécurité une
espèce de cadres qu'ils ne trouvent plus
actuellement dans la vie quotidienne
même pas dans leur famille le service de
demain les adolescents l'imaginent
souple avec de l'ordre et plus de
formation où une majorité d'entre eux un
service national à la carte civils ou
militaires
enfin ces jeunes souhaitent davantage
d'effectifs féminin dans les casernes
qui s'en étonnera oui dans tous ces
jeunes connaîtront par coeur la
marseillaise comme le demande monsieur
chevènement alors ce seront de vrais
patriotes l'histoire